the force released two years ago I had
high hopes for the division I love the
thought of an open world Manhattan I'm a
sucker for post-apocalyptic stories and
I'm also a longtime fan of Tom Clancy
games and their tactical combat so like
some I was disappointed when I finally
played it instead of a seamless open
world to explore with my friends I found
the skeleton of a game built around an
artificial loot grind what's more that
Luc Ryan wasn't all that rewarding or
even fun to begin with I was completing
fetch quests and shooting bullet sponge
enemies over and over again lastly I
felt as if developer massive
entertainment had failed to use its
premise to good effect playing as
peacekeeping agents sent into a post
outbreak New York seemed like a
springboard for grim storytelling but
here too the game fell flat characters
were cheesy and any interesting
questions massive raised were brushed
aside in favor of loot and boring
reasons to find it suffice it to say I
bounced off the division hard but of
course the game was a commercial
juggernaut it was the most successful
new franchise to date selling 330
million dollars in its first five days
eclipsing Bungie's destiny by 5 million
in the same period whatever problems I
had with the game didn't seem to
register with a huge number of people
and those numbers have only grown just
two weeks ago Ubisoft announced that the
division had accrued 20 million total
players much like Ubisoft Studios have
done with Rainbow six siege and Ghost
Recon wildlands they've constantly
supported the division in its post
release months its popularity has
allowed the team to implement continual
updates and those updates have kept
increasing the game's popularity it's a
symbiotic relationship that has more for
the division into something very
different than its original form and of
course just recently massive announced
it will be showing the division 2 at e3
this year a sequel was inevitable for
the most successful new franchise of all
time but still it piqued my curiosity
once again I decided to finally give the
division a second chance to see how it
had changed see whether I could embrace
it for what it is now what I want it to
be so this is my experience with the
division 2 years and 20 million players
later
[Music]
let's get the biggest roadblocks out of
the way up front the division is still a
grind it is not a tactical shooter it's
open world is not teeming with memorable
characters and revelatory secrets it is
still largely focused on pushing you
through a gameplay loop of traveling
shooting looting and crafting it is
still Ubisoft main attempt to rival
lifestyle games such as destiny but only
two hours into my recent playthrough it
was apparent just how much more variety
there is this time around in your search
for loot you can hunt down bounties
clear contaminated areas extract virus
samples and defend allied checkpoints
that's not to mention endgame content
such as high-value targets the wave
based resistance mode the 4v4 skirmish
arena the randomized underground
missions or server wide global events
some of these were paid DLC while year
two expansions were all free updates the
division is still very much a grind but
in general that grind is now much more
fun the process is also much more
rewarding enemies constantly drop items
useful for your character rank as I work
to increase my endgame ranking I was
getting new rewards for everything I did
of course that doesn't mean you can't
get attached to your favorite loop in
update 1.3 the division added the
recalibration station allowing you to
re-roll item stats to better suit your
character this seemingly minor addition
is actually huge it lets you keep gear
with high armor rating without
sacrificing the build you're working
toward I can have my cake and eat it too
all-in-all the division does a much
better job of letting me play how I want
there are certain activities that will
undoubtedly provide better loot drops
but in the long haul any time I spend
with a division will likely improve my
character there are more ways to get
loot there are more ways to customize my
play style and there are more ways to
explore this crumbling man hat
[Music]
when it comes to the division's game
world I'm torn I agree with many that
there is wasted potential here a
diseased New York perpetually covered in
holiday decorations with warring
factions trying to survive it's a dream
premise for many writers sadly that
story never really flourishes its
factions for instance have some of the
weakest motivations I can imagine the
city sanitation workers all came
together as the flamethrower toting
cleaners they walked the city burning
everything in sight people included
hoping to rid the world of the new
plague the Rikers on the other hand are
all escaped convicts from the infamous
Rikers Island prison they forms beneath
a murderous leader hoping to use their
criminal ways to claim New York for
their own if you're thinking this all
sounds ham-fisted I agree
furthermore the game had the opportunity
to ask questions about whether you and
your fellow division agents are actually
the good guys you're sent in to maintain
the government during the collapse and
you're given free reign to kill anyone
threatening that agenda but anytime the
division approaches tougher subject
matter it stumbles opting instead to
justify our actions in service to the
greater loot right
and I've got a hell of a lot more than
good intentions we're gonna do this and
we're gonna do it the right way all of
this being said though I am thoroughly
impressed by the world design itself
it's not on par with Los Santos or
breadth of the wilds Hyrule but as far
as settings go massives Manhattan is
beautiful in its modern desolation it's
also remarkable how well the game
manages to fit a third-person cover
based shooter so fluidly into this world
each Street is a potential ambush point
every alleyway a good snipers
line-of-sight massives New York
comprises a multitude of smaller shooter
arenas sewn together into one seamless
hole it's hard to ignore the craft on
display here and this all brings me to
the dark zone what was probably the
game's main attraction before release
soon became a source of headaches for
players and developers alike the center
of Manhattan was the only original PvP
arena in the division allowing agents to
farm high-end loot while also teaming up
with or betraying other human players
doing the latter meant going rogue
essentially painting a target on your
back and making you a lucrative bounty
for deer seeking players um
major problem with all this was balance
or lack thereof at first the penalties
for dying as a rogue agent were so steep
that almost no one ever risked it as new
updates rolled out those consequences
softened however each new update brought
a new wave of cheaters who exploited the
game for seemingly impossible loot drops
by entering the dark zone with extremely
unbalanced gear these players pretty
much ran the PvP arena without any real
opposition toss in the fact that all you
had to do to go rogue was to shoot
another player and the dark zone became
a chaotic nightmare players were jumping
into my line-of-sight forcing me to
become an outlaw against my will
shortly before killing me and claiming
their bounty thankfully the recent
update 1.8 fixed that problem to go
rogue now you have to notify other
players before attacking them this may
sound sort of goofy and gamified but it
works well the tension and mind games
that accompany loot extractions are
still tantalizing as ever not knowing
whether someone will help you fend off
AI enemies or turn on you at the last
second is downright terrifying it's an
intriguing look at your trustworthiness
and your ability to trust in this
chaotic environment full as it is with a
legendary gear ripe for the taking there
are still balance issues in the dark
zone as many players will inevitably
have better weapons than others but the
changes massive have made give me hope
for the dark zone and the sequel in fact
the entirety of the division feels like
an ambitious experiment finally yielding
results the more time massive and
Ubisoft have spent with it the more they
seem to understand what makes it tick
and the more they can shape it into
something unique it's one of those
series that feels on the cusp of
excellence if only it could take those
last few necessary steps
I just hope massive avoids the missteps
Bungie recently made in making a sequel
that didn't seem to learn all that much
from its predecessor for several months
after destiny 2 is released it felt as
if Bungie ignored the progress they had
made with the first game's patches
updates and expansions I don't mean to
keep kicking destiny while it's down it
just feels as if Bungie takes one step
forward for every two steps back and
while we're on the topic of similar
games it's no secret that the division
takes cues from Diablo 3 both our loot
grinds both have item recalibration
procedural late-game dungeons and gear
sets that lend more
personality to your equipment in general
both games are about finding loot
optimizing it and using it to get better
loot until you have the best items
possible for X amount of time but I
think the division is chasing Diablo 3
in a wider sense - when it first
released Diablos grind was far less
rewarding than it is now players spent
much more time seeking the specific gear
they wanted and unique items with
noticeable abilities were few and far
between as the dungeon crawler evolved
however the rewards became more constant
legendary items had more personality
loot was more useful and the time you
spent was more likely to be worth it
judging from the time I put into the
divisions late-game content it still has
problems to fix before it reaches its
full potential exotic items should stand
out farther from the crowd and they
should help me more in my pursuit of
specific character builds but like
Diablo massive has shown it can make the
whole grind more rewarding it just needs
to capitalize in the sequel the
developers have already said they're
making the division - with all of their
recent learning in mind they've said
they're using the new and improved
division 1 as a starting point for
future success I hope this rings true
I hope they pull it off the division is
much better than I remember it being in
2016 and if massive truly learned from
this entire process it might not take me
two years to give it sequel the
attention it deserves